direction le marché de noël de tours à
présent ou plutôt les marchés de noël
quatre lieux différents qui ont ouvert à
17 heures boulevard heurteloup mais
aussi place châteauneuf place
anatole-france et place de la résistance
chacun avec une dizaine de cabanes
version inédite donc cette année
qu'ovide oblige sur place en haut de la
rue nationale on retrouverait les
renault et les ingrédients sont bien là
des lumières de noël et puis les fameux
petits chalets qu'on retrouve donc cette
année aux quatre coins de la ville de
tours il ya bien sûr le grand sapin
et puis sous les chalets les artisans et
les commerçants il ya par exemple
christelle de la savonnerie de villandry
christelle chez vous les savons sont
ultra locaux c'est ça oui bonjour
en fait je les fabrique moi-même donc
sur place abbey landry ses parts à
bonifications à froid vous aviez hâte de
retrouver vos clients les passants pour
ce marché de noël
oui on a failli être que les marchés de
noël reprennent parce qu'en fait bas on
prend plaisir à fabriquer nos propres
créations donc moi ce n'est pas de savon
mais après il ya autant de plaisir à
discuter avec les gens à partager
expliqué oui notre métier notre
savoir-faire en fait il y en a pour tous
les goûts pour toutes les couleurs et
puis 500 rue demanderont merci beaucoup
christelle on va aller voir n'aura
lorsqu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est
que le marché de noël les marchés de
noël ont lieu du vendredi au dimanche de
10h à 19h on va aller voir nos rois qui
elle fabrique des bijoux
nora vous êtes installé au bout et bien
moi j'habite à chance et juste quelques
kilomètres d'ici en fait je suis du coin
et puis je fabrique tous les bijoux
depuis une dizaine d'années maintenant
et je fais le marché de noël depuis près
de six ans vous êtes une habituée c'est
une vraie habitude qu'ont les
tourangeaux aussi de venir ici et puis
de rencontrer les artisans tu mens
complètement et puis c'est sympa parce
que c'est vraiment rendez vous en faites
avec ma clientèle qu'à l'habitude de me
retrouver là et puis de voir mes
nouvelles créations et c'était un jeu je
me déplace chez vous vous dépêchez on
vous retrouve donc tous les week-ends
jusqu'au 20 décembre et puis si vous
avez envie de voir le père noël parce
que noël sans le père noël oui ce serait
pas ça serait pas noël bien alors le
père noël sur les marchés donc deux
tours il viendra les samedis mettez donc
ça dans votre agenda